Ukrainians Ukrainians of the whole group 177 days at
such an hour cool stings the abyss of Ukraine my
significant content left Ukrainian
diplomats our partners for the country to the
UN and the IAEA, but it strengthens more specifically the
details of the mission to us as if on a promo in the
west quattro well, become 7 and 7 already
read it  plan full of
gas mister with and you on the radar I will explain the symptom by
pronouncing such work by the initiative of the
all-Russian blackmail radiation
will continue, then the goal may be to the studio of the
European regions the code for you know the
tragic owls now burned
instructions found not a single station
apparently preferred order divide by  that
brood I still like I held back the terrorist
territory with on michel we notice in the mouth
today the form then y by x and by 1 6 from the
Russian blackmail deck nr attacks
again smeared it takes
minutes through long rhythmic paths and
again study the absurd statement about 1000 I
will not be possible  sit down to compensate and through the
primary path to two
types of current consumption of Russia you are the reason
for  the account will knock and in Europe the
problems they are stupidly hoe let there immediately
at a time you absolutely general withdrawal of our
longer power is a terrorist but i for
lie down on the European my saint
similar market who will have to
stability on the market and the more
the enemy forces prepare their
energy systems for out
there was a knock in the hall without Budnikov and he brings peace
with Russia, you’ll be better able to
survive Fokin and you’ll be winters